Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
the chapter of truth and truthfulness
authored by Al
Farad
Abu Zakaria
said he
saidch.
[Silence]
And this narration here collected by
both bkari and Muslim on the authority
of
his.
He narrates that the messenger of Allah.
Wasam said that the two
involved the two parties involved in
a sales transaction
have a choice to reverse or nullify the
sales transaction as long as they do not
leave one another's company. So we have
the person selling, the person buying,
they have this agreement. even if
each even if each takes what is his, the
merchant takes his pay, the
customer takes his merchandise. As long
as they do not leave one another's
company, the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam here tells us that they still
have the choice and the option to
nullify or to go back on the sale if
they think better of it. If they choose
to reverse the sale, they have that
right and they have that choice as long
as they do not leave one another's
company. And this here this concept of
a transaction being completed
once a person
leaves the company of the person they
are transacting with. This is something
that other rulings in Islam are built
upon. So I'll give you an example. Let's
say a person says takes a vow a vow to
do something. Person swears by Allah
that they will fast tomorrow. Say I
swear by Allah I will fast tomorrow.
And then they go about their day. Later
on they think better of it and they say
inshallah
that vow has now ended.
Once that person has moved on to another
sentence, to another thought, to another
idea, to another issue,
if they were to say that for instance
they are going to fast tomorrow
and then without interjecting with any
other statement, with any other idea,
with any other issue, with any other
subject. And then they were to say
inshallah
this now has the ruling of it. When does
it end? When does that window close? The
window closes once another subject has
been introduced.
This here is the same concept and that
is that as long as they are in one
another's company which means they have
not moved on to something else in their
lives they still have the choice to
reverse this transaction
once they have moved on to something
else and left one another's company. Now
this transaction becomes completed.
In another wording of this same
narration, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says
he mentions three days.
So how do we how do we harmonize that
narration and this narration? In this
narration, he's saying as long as they
don't leave one another's company. In
that narration, he's saying three days.
Well, sales transactions are very
different in their nature, aren't they?
Some transactions are as simple as
buying a stick of gum or buying some
fruit, right? Whilst others are a little
bit more serious and need a time
allotted in order for that transaction
to finalize due to the gravity of the
transaction. If a person is buying a
house, buying a car, buying something
that is very expensive, then this is
something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam gave more time to. Is 3
days the maximum? No.
This narration is speaking about that
which does not have a norm in the
market. But if we were to agree, let's
say myself as a customer and one of you
as the merchant that I tell you what we
will make it a monthl long you have a
month which many places do you have 30
days to return something then that is
okay it doesn't go against this
narration or the other why because this
is a condition that we place on our
sales transactions. It changes based on
time and place and customs. So as the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said in a
[Silence]
that the believers are held to the
conditions that they stipulate upon one
another when they conduct any
transaction
except for a condition that makes halal
what is otherwise haram or a condition
what makes haram what is otherwise
halal.
Now why is this narration
in this chapter? Because remember this
chapter is about truthfulness.
The shahit part of the narration or the
part that is pertinent to this chapter
is where he says
Foreign
[Silence]
so here the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam says so if they both are
transparent and truthful in their sale
Allah will place bar in that sale in
that transaction
transparent meaning the seller is
transparent if there's any defect or
anything wrong with with what they're
selling and also the buyer needs to be
transparent
an example the faukahhat give is let's
say I come to buy something from someone
who's unaware of the market value of
what they're trying to sell. And so
let's say it's a watch they're selling
me and it's worth 200, but they're
selling it for a hundred.
But they don't know that it's worth more
than that. If they know, that's their
choice. But if they do not know that
it's worth more than that for me to
proceed with that and not tell them
especially if they are Muslim but not
only if they are Muslim this is
considered this is considered haram and
this will take away the blessing of my
transaction.
likewise
He says, "And if they conceal and lie in
their transaction,
then the blessing of their transaction
will be removed, will be stunted by
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala based on how
much they lie and how much they
conceal."
The narrator of this hadith
went to buy a horse from another
companion and he bought the horse for a
hundred
me
which is a lot of money at the time.
However, once he left, he realized that
it was worth a lot more than that. And
he went back to him. And he went back to
him a number of times until he had ended
up more than quadrupling the amount that
he initially gave him.
Why? Because that is what he is seeking.
He is seeking the bar from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He is not seeking
to keep a dollar in his pocket that
will taint the rest of his wealth and
will be a cause for concern with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. A dollar
spared
which has no baraka in it is a disaster.
It is a punishment from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. A dollar spent with baraka is
far superior than a dollar spared with
without
[Arabic recitation]
that
make it simple and they are trying to
sell it for three or 400. This is not
only a major sin but it is exactly the
same that is said for the other way
around that we mentioned which is
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala dispraised
for what reason is
because they would devour
and because they would take people's
wealth without right to do so. Any of
these types of things is considered to
be haram. And anything that is beyond
reason and beyond market value to a
point where it is excessive is haram.
And when does this most introduce
itself? When people are desperate,
right? If I know you can only get it
from me.
And now I'm saying, well, you don't have
to buy it, right? Well, no. You really
actually do have to buy it, don't you?
You do have to buy it. But this is where
morality and capitalism in its most
brutal form clash. And that is
capitalism is hey listen, if I have the
money and you don't, I make the rules.
That's capitalism.
in Islam, we don't have these kinds
of concepts. The concepts are Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala makes the rules and
I am neither allowed to abuse my
customers nor as a customer am I allowed
to abuse my merchant
even if it's a big company even if it's
a huge conglomerate and you know
people people justify their behaviors in
all kinds of ways for instance here
in our country,
how do people abuse one another?
Merchants abuse customers by
monopolizing a market, causing people to
to forcing people's hand. Look at the
health care system for instance. You buy
150 bucks for an aspirin. Why? Because
we can. Because this is this is medical
aspirin, right?
You want some tissues. This is medical
quality tissues. $30 a box. You want to
stay in this bed here. This is, you
know, if it were in a hotel room, it
would be $200. Being that it's in this
hospital, it's going to be $50,000 a
night, right? Why? Because you have no
other choice. But then they say, "Well,
you don't have to come." Yeah, actually,
you do have to come, right? So
monopolizing
and doing other schemes that we can get
into at another time inshallah such as
things that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam prohibited buying
up all the stock and then hoarding it in
order for the value to go up and then
selling it. The prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
very much dis disavowed people who
do this right but customers also
abuse these merchants. I say well you
know
this is a really big company. They're
not going to miss this or insurance
fraud or any of these other things that
people do because they're crooks. So,
I'll get over on them if I can.
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa tala.